well good day to you I think we can we
can begin today with us we have a we
have a guest Jim Alexander and maybe the
best description of jim was somebody
somebody said that he was the fly in the
end rond-point meant and he wouldn't say
a little bit more about how he was in
the the Enron pointment and in what ways
he functioned also as a fly and try to
draw out his experiences in that company
as well then as in spinnaker a company
and startup company which he started
after that which almost to serve as kind
of polar opposites of for James James
own experience in the business business
world so we're delighted the gym wooden
is with us I think this is his second or
third time part of this course and again
he's always back on the popular demand
thanks Jim and Jim is local here to
lives in New Haven I need to remind all
of you to use your microphones and if I
forget to remind you would you please
remind me to remind you to use the
microphones that'd be great okay so so
today we're talking about corporations
and in particular relationship between
faiths faith traditions and values and
corporations larger setting in which we
are making this discussion is the
previous session where we talked about
market as a whole well we kind of did
right in one section of the session we
did and the other section we immediately
went toward the corporation and
particular predicament in which a given
corporation Cadbury had found itself a
wonderful condition that we have had led
by Sharon oyster so and the prior to
that our larger framework was a brief
discussion about the character of faiths
in the world
today secularization this D
secularization with Casanova present as
a resource person and prior to then
after that a section on globalization
both perils and promise of globalization
I think we more majored on the promise
of globalization than on perils but
nonetheless this is this is kind of a
larger framework of what we have done so
far just a brief reminder why
corporations I think somewhere I for a
degree who was a resource person for
this class and who teaches at school of
management he has said in the previous
session that he's led on corporations
values and corporations that about
eighty to ninety percent of all wealth
in capitalist economies is created by
corporations by limited liability
corporations corporations then become a
very powerful institutions in the world
today especially when one thinks about
their multi national character and key
feature of the of corporations and we'll
explore some of that with Jim is that
owners essentially have a little way of
controlling the business and even
knowing what the business does and
therefore a certain separation of
management from ownership so that the
managerial class as a third in the kind
of classical Marxian sense of classes
are those class of workers class of
capitalists and but there's this
managerial a class which is quite
distinct and extraordinarily powerful
and that presents itself with a host of
significant ethical issues some of these
we will explore as we talk with Jim
about these issues now what I want to do
is just briefly sketch a role of fades
within possible roles of fades within
corporations and then also kind of a
place of people of faith within
corporation those are two different
sides of the same question so how do
corporations relate to faith traditions
that will be the first question and
that's a question that
arises with the character of the
globalised world namely with emergence
of religious pluralism suddenly just
like the states so also corporations are
religiously pluralistic spaces and just
like religious actors want to act as
religious actors in the public space so
also they want to increasingly do that
in the context of a corporation
traditionally within the business world
faith was considered just as in the kind
of secular state is a private matter you
are believer at home and you're believer
in your church mosques in a go temple
whatever you go in the private sphere of
the community of faith but not at the
place of work you should hang your faith
on the coat rack enter into workplace
and their function as a rational human
being as a kind of generic human being
and when you get up off the work in your
private sphere we can be whatever you
want to be it's kind of somebody has
mentioned discussion groups at least so
it was reported to me that it was kind
of don't ask don't tell policy of course
people war people of faith but you
weren't supposed to be talking too much
about this and the reason why you
weren't supposed to be talked too much
about it this is one that your faith
traditions have little to do with
business at hand and two is because if
you bring up faith faith is a divisive
issue especially issues like proselytism
in applying of the pressure on people to
embrace faith conditions in which only
certain forms of faith are acceptable
within the workplace whole host of
issues that have to do a deal with
unequal treatment of various faiths
within the corporation you can see why
people would want to minimize friction
and therefore suppress the expressions
of faith and that's was then of course
analogous to how the place of faith in
within the state right
air to state was supposed to at least
some accounts be more secular and
people's faith commitments to be more
private it's difficult to have this to
sustain this straight division between
private and in public and it's difficult
to sustain it I think increasingly also
within a corporation to fate is shaping
the way people act and especially more
people become kind of knowledge workers
rather than assembly line kinds of
workers a place of faith I think there's
more space for the play faith to insert
itself and people have at least some
people have started discovering as we
have seen in some of our readings that
faith can be an asset for business you
can harness the power of faith to serve
the business purposes now people of
faith may have ambivalent position and
feelings about this but nonetheless that
also opens up the possibility of faith
being present in within the corporation
expressions of faith being being
welcomed and I think that roughly my
position there is a very parallel to the
position of the the role of faith in the
place of faith in liberal democracies
liberal democracies ought to be
impartial to all different expressions
of faith all overarching interpretations
of life all public spaces ought to be
impartial two expressions of faith and
if they're not impartial if they are
either radically secular or if they're
partial to a particular faith they are
not treating all their citizens equally
and so there's prima facie an argument I
think for the for allowing of the
expressions of faith within the
corporation but doing so on the equal
basis assuring impartiality and of
course you'll have to monitor ways
procedures in which that's being done so
that it isn't disruptive just like you
have to do that the same thing
the context of the in the political
context okay so but what's the what what
does the fade do in corporations so okay
so you'll you'll let it be there but
what mighty do within that space of a
corporation and I think from the
readings that we had for today you could
divide what faith might do or not do in
terms of economic performance and in
terms of moral framework that it brings
and the case that we have we have read
is from Indonesia crockett I'll steal I
think it's a very interesting case study
in a sense of insertion of translation
in some ways of faith into a different
mode and connecting it with the the work
of business faith first there was not
understood as something that belongs to
a private sphere but rather something
that should inform all spheres of life
private and communal spheres of course
but also what people do in everyday life
and then two major moves as you will
recall one was connection between work
and calling or work and worship your own
work worship is not limited to what you
do in your privacy of your home or in
the temple worship is what you do in the
everyday life that kind of a line you
can see in Christianity you can see it
in Judaism you can see it also in Islam
so that the worship permeate or
permeates all of your life therefore
also what you do of a new earth place of
work and consequence of that is a
certain form of discipline right certain
form of responsibility to do the job as
doing it as religious duty and the line
that's there or sometimes it's very that
is used is faith as being done for God
you work for God as you work for your
earthly employees now you
see how that might be easily misused
right earthly employee is not God right
there's a distinction between the two
and that there's going to be a tension
between the claims of God on your in
claims of the concrete space in which
you find yourself and I think that's
going to be an interesting question to
to pursue of course and then the other
side of it was the one was faith or work
as worship and the other one was
accountability a sense that you don't
need to be monitored from outside but it
you can be because you do your work
before God and for God you can be
counted on that you will do your work
honestly responsibility responsibly and
so forth and will address some of these
some of these issues as we explore with
Jim as we explore what are the cake to
do honest work in the context of a
corporation kind of ethical framework
and knowledge of what is right the piece
that we read on their suggest you know
most people actually know what's right
so the problem is not so much knowing
what is right but being somehow having
ability in the context in which you find
yourself to do what is right now what
we'll explore with Jim is what is the
context and what are the pressures of
that particular context that push you're
not quite to do what is right and how
can resistances be made to the pressure
to do what might not quite be morally
right so now in this case that we've
that we've read the presupposition
almost seems to be that if you employ
properly your faith it's going to
enhance economic performance and faith
is somehow going to add to the value
it's going to be kind of value-added
it's going to add to the creation of
value but the question then from the
internal question of faith becomes well
defines what value is and if i read this
piece rightly it seems that the value is
being defined as any corporation might
define it as maximizing profit but is
that acceptable from the perspective of
faith and the question might not be well
should fades a firm profitability
because lot of fates at least these days
think that profits as such is not a
problem but it's a problem we that's the
soul and the most important issue
yesterday we've had discussion case
study we were looked at at the center
that I ran and there were twenty three
case studies that are now being done but
various companies from all across the
world who which are in some ways shaped
by religious sensibilities or leadership
has been shaped by religious
sensibilities and imbued that into the
work of the other corporation one of
these such such was chick-fil-a and
first one that we know we've looked at
case studies now virtually finished and
the significant factor there is well
they closed the their shop on Sundays
right that's Lourdes days being honored
there and somehow that translates into
improved economic performance and one of
the top one of the topics of our
discussion was well is that what we
should be simply concerned about how
about the faith how about the what
happens to how much the workers are
being employees are being paid or ease
would the added value be if you could
hire and keep hired thousand employees
but your profits will be reduced to
about one cent below above above the
fader going in going into internet right
what is the value and I think the faith
traditions will ask the questions of the
character of Alison generally it would
sit not seat so eat well with them if
the
it's defined simply in terms of
profitability trips of maximizing profit
will talk with Jim about that as well
when we come to spinnaker so we'll draw
most of this stuff that we are
discussing now out of gym and out of
concrete experience of him running those
various businesses and then I think what
waits also a break and I'll be
relatively brief is and we've talked
about that already before is kind of
moral judgments about work that's being
done now when I say moral judgments I
think some of you might scratch your
heads and say who needs moralizing fades
right who needs fades to tell me what is
morally acceptable or not for folks we
embrace fades certain fades fades tend
to do that and most people think that if
fades don't in some way help you read
the world in moral terms that they're
not doing their job properly you recall
what I've said that fades can be reduced
to kind of performance-enhancing drugs
right oh it can be kind of upper has a
performance-enhancing drug and help
soothing dragon this was a major
critique right marks and critique we
recall marks and critique of religion
religion is opiate of the people major
critique was the only function that the
religion have is kind of to soothe the
sentiments of people have them dream
about the world to come so that they can
not bother too much the processes is
there going on in the world as it is as
it is today kind of privatized it
completely make it otherworldly so that
it doesn't have a bite in the world
today now but if fates do have bite in
the world today then of course the
question arises will do we do we like
what fades demand the Justice kind of
ways in which fades understand justice
so you have fades often then oscillating
between withdrawal or kind of what I
call sometimes idleness of faith babe if
they if they
I to shape the world as I think major
prophetic religions are all structurally
built to do Judaism Christianity Islam
are prophetic religions and in that
sense the prophet receive is kind of a
message from God in order to apply it to
the world but it fades do that suddenly
many people experience that as a kind of
inappropriate insertion as violence and
if fates withdraw then they become
subject to kind of Marxian critique
their Idol they're doing basically
nothing they kind of sued private
private consciousness of people help
them in their everyday life but actually
have no significant impact on the world
as it being it is being good and so you
have fades often oscillating between
insertion sometimes may be inappropriate
insertion and then we draw and the
question I think for faith tradition is
always well how does one find ways in
which to insert oneself inappropriate
way in the pluralistic context and
that's what creates the that where the
rabbit that's where the rubber hits the
road we have a pluralistic context of
people who do not necessarily agree with
each other so at any rate there is moral
judgments which creates make and those
moral judgments concern both how the
work should be done and also what should
be done you know there's a distinction
in the in the Christian tradition at
least but other tradition as well when
it comes to the Just War when is it just
to engage in war and you have a
distinction between use in Bello justice
in the conduct of the word war and use
add value just cause for engaging in
more like action I think something
similar can be said also about
economically indeed about most of the
spheres you can ask the question well
what how is it what is just in terms of
conduct of business
how you treat workers whatever out that
else that might be and or what kind of
activities what kind of business
products outcomes are just and worthy of
being pursued and sometimes the question
is not simply also what's right or wrong
sometimes I think that the question is
what might be morally excellent and
morally excellent as a different ish
it's a different issue but it's
important issue for instance you might
you might say okay I was I was one one
day I hope it until the circuit I was I
was on a cruise few years ago black tie
dinner reception and I'm with with a guy
and he I'm asking what what's he doing
and so he tells me well you will laugh
miroslav I said well try me and he said
I'm making urinals and I pause a little
to say well most of us most of us men
need them you know so it's okay it's a
kind of good and he said I'm I'm in the
business of flush free making flash free
urinals now that's an excellent work
right it's not if he was making regular
urinals he could have that very nice job
making regular urinals it would have
been just completely appropriate ethical
II of praise were they kind of work that
he was doing but instead he was doing
something I think which was morally
excellent right he was attending to the
needs of the planet right as he was
pursuing his business and so the
question becomes not only what's allowed
or not allowed but what might be
excellent and I think we might we might
think in terms of how to stimulate our
imagination to think of ways in which
without sacrificing necessarily profit
what might attend not only to people but
also to plan triple bottom line these
people sometimes dark right and in a
certain form of excellence is required
in order to do that and I think
excellence it's required can be
stimulated
a variety of sources from it can come
from a variety of sources but certainly
faith traditions can contribute to that
it to the extent that faith traditions
talks about what it means to flourish as
a human being and to the extent that
they talk about what it means to pursue
global common good in the context of a
grand vision of human flourishing as
well as the as of the global common good
we might want to pursue the question of
what is excellent of course excellent
will always be in the context of what's
doable right but nonetheless the
excellent question is a significant
question to to address so what also is
sometimes suggest that is that the way
traditions are able to do is not simply
suggest what ought to be done but
provide a certain motivation to be able
to do that that may be a disputed claim
but at least one has to understand that
from internal self perception of faiths
fates are not simply ethical systems
their ethical systems with built-in
motivations as to why what is being
required ought to be done and if it's
true that most of us roughly know what's
to be done but when you come into a
critical situation we're not sure that
it's worth doing it or we're not sure
that we have enough strength to do it
and then religious traditions might be
of some help in this regard critical
situations as such arise I think
constantly not just in the business they
arise constantly in everyday kind of
alive compromises that we have to make
and difficulties in making judgments not
just making judgments but then going
going through with those judgments in
that regard I think we might think about
the role that religious traditions play
and hence we often the colleague of mine
is working on
on kind of applying virtue ethic to the
question of business it's not just
teaching rules but nurturing the types
of people that are able in concrete
situation to act in accordance with
those rules that kind of raises a
question whether the whole industry of
business ethics is that significant of
an endeavor now the last person to try
to speak against business ethics but to
the extent that the discussion is simply
about how what is right or what is wrong
or at least to simply raise this
question of right and wrong it may we
may not be doing enough we may be
soothing our conscience that we are
doing something but in fact may be doing
too little because we are not nurturing
the types of people who are able to act
in concrete situations as one ought to
act now a cynic might say if you haven't
learned that by year ten you probably
haven't learned any time after that you
know that's what happens way back at
home but whatever the the area I think
it's important to keep in mind the
importance of the virtue in this context
and that of course doesn't doesn't it
all mean that regulation is unnecessary
or that even thinking about how the work
environment itself is structured doesn't
have a moral implications and I think
especially as we think about corporation
I think I hope that we would Jim we can
explore in what ways the very nature of
the setup called corporation militates
against the ability to act in morally
responsible ways so that the form of
corporation itself is an ethical you
shoe regulation of course but the form
of the corporation itself now i think
i'm going to stop right here and i'm
going to go with these few challenges
that we have here about how to act
morally responsible ways within the
corporation I'll go straight and
discussion to it regime and then we'll
take a break and have a more broader
conversation